[Music]
[Applause]
hey
welcome to the break room we're thrilled
to be here with you happy friday
everybody uh this is the show that keeps
you updated on all the nerdy news you
need to know live from the new rock
stars actual break room here on our los
angeles campus uh we are 100 live to
prove that campus
there you go tommy
we've got a lot of really fun stuff to
talk about today mostly we are going to
fix dc for you guys
we've got we've got some plans some
options uh we're gonna craft a 10-year
plan
for them and just hand it to them on a
plate we also got some guardians of the
galaxy news um and
this is both a promise and a threat
tommy bechtold
we'll shave his chest we're shaving fans
we've been we've been saying all week uh
if we get to a certain threshold in
super chat dollars tommy will shave
something into his chest yeah we are 125
away currently from that threshold so if
you throw a couple doubloons in the old
super chat which we always appreciate
thank you to everybody who does that
at 125
tommy you are going to shave the word
jess into your chest
in honor
thriving
now we don't know what'll happen when
you shave her name into your jazz that
that that could that could be like a
voodoo dog yeah i was wondering like how
will she feel it will she know yeah oh
she'll know does she get power
she'll know also are you shaving it in
yourself yeah yeah like mirror style
will it be in reverse yeah right oh i
gotta think about that i don't know if
i'm smart enough to do this
we gotta get to the second level yeah
there's only one way to find out chat
you gotta throw us a couple bucks also
that that's at 125
we decided to we can raise the game a
little bit if we hit 300
tommy is going in his words hardwood
floors and he's going to shave his
entire chest
longer than these shows
and uh finally and this is i hope we do
not hit this one i do i truly hope this
does not happen keep the trimming if if
we reach 500. tommy is going to save the
save all the hairy things off
we are going to either tape or glue it
to my hairless yeah
that is a sleek
aerodynamic machine i'm like a dolphin
under this hawaiian let's give them a
little place
before you'll find it with the aperture
as well
uh it's gonna be a real
a real s show today yeah um friday
freaky friday it's gonna be very idiot
swapping bodies are gonna be swapping
chest hair oh
i think that pushes us over or we're
very close to the top he has to shave
jessica's four dollars away four bucks
thank you mr krabs uh
nobody give another sense
um of course follow the break room on
tick tock we've been doing some fun work
over there at the underscore break room
um and let's go ahead
while we wait for a few more dollars to
accrue for tommy straight to be sealed
yes let's get into some headlines hey
did we introduce everyone i did not i
don't
know daryl
we are the headliner
today the only person we named was the
person who's right
don't trust the media not guilty
[Applause]
that's my new catchphrase okay
yeah i mean it's just i'm just covering
my base yeah very good smart people like
what episode did you declare your
innocence i say absolutely 68 years
before you were accused of anything um
okay but yes let's get into some
headlines uh so
um
this is a real fun one oh yeah if you've
been to an amc i have to step out and
shave just in my chest okay wow
he's not gonna see a lot of tommy today
rodriguez wait what are you shaving with
uh the man
yeah by the way this redemption is
sponsored by our sponsor manscaped uh
not just for use on your pubic hair yeah
any hair could be chest hair yeah skin
safe technology while i'm in there i
might just go to town okay don't don't
you dare save that hair i'm shaving jess
and i'm shaving
down below
okay uh yes uh so um yeah you'll be
familiar with this if you've been in an
amc theater in the last year those great
nicole kidman
intros that's news the week are queen
yes heartbreak feels good in a place
like this um she's renewed
she's going to be doing more she's going
to continue her reign as the official
spokesman person for both anti-theaters
and just the movie-going experiences in
general can we acknowledge that this
happened the week of all this dc
heartbreak and how nicole has our back
and she's like i'm going to step right
out of aquaman i'm going to make sure
that everyone knows that while you're
going through this heartbreak it does
feel a little better name c yeah
absolutely i love it we were joking i
mean it's such a perfect like psa or
whatever that plays we almost don't want
her to do a new draft of it but how
could she raise the game of those psas
what do you think the 2020 pursuit
i would also like more clips
yes i want to see her dressed as
characters she has played so her her
lucille ball yeah her her battered
housewife from um uh what was the name
of the show
yes
go back to days of thunder yes yes yes
oh wow
okay
we did not charge the uh man's gate very
important through no fault of manscape
this is completely awful yeah this is
our fault we're not saying enough about
the product guys
but it doesn't need a charge
that charges the battery that's the
first three steps this is gonna come in
here there you go you got the you got
the brick you got the cube okay more
proof this was not pre-taped yes
you need the cube there it is oh good
answer
we'll get to see that was a little
before shot thank you tommy um
uh so
the big topic of the day what we've been
talking about for the last two days
uh warner brothers and all the craziness
that's going on with dc and warner
brothers in general um david zaslov
who's currently the ceo of warner
discovery had a uh an investor call
yesterday we kind of reiterated some of
the things we've heard so far this week
and then gave some more information uh
he did confirm that the flash film will
be released as of now and he also
name-checked black adam shazam um and
saying we have some great dc films
coming up
interestingly he did not name aquaman
two
huh
probably just an oversight yeah he was
yeah
those are so many
yeah no is coming out flat before flash
so it's if i'm remember frankie black
adam
black adam shazam because they're a
month apart yeah aquaman early next year
flash summer temp yes oh okay maybe it
gets moved because of the ben affleck
stuff oh maybe they didn't say it
because they didn't want to raise
awareness for it right before they move
it yeah
who knows because if they're reshooting
right now and and maybe that's a better
thing like i'd rather the movie come out
done then come out early
when the release date moves i'm always
optimistic and that's just who i am yeah
but i think it's for the best if a movie
feels like it's as ready as it can be
yeah yeah and i love dc comic characters
like i'm excited about all these movies
i'm gonna go see them i'm excited about
the rock being black adam and you know
coming back in whatever capacity and
whoever you see yes all right
and again we are going to we are going
to lay out a 10-year plan for dc coming
up in a segment later on throw out start
throwing out actually in the chat if you
have some films you think need to be a
part of dc's upcoming 10-year plan
through that out there uh you think like
whatever they do they cannot
not make x film um and uh speaking of dc
stuff we've been speculating what else
could be canceled what else uh what
other kind of potential properties both
hbo max and theatrical and our our very
own um currently shaving tommy vector
did get it confirmed somebody hopped
into his dms and this is a reliable
source
confirmed with him yesterday that
production for the penguin hbo max
series begins the beginning of next year
wow so that that project has not been
canceled it's still
in the works production begins
presumably in january thank you to that
scooper thank you to tommy bechdel for
reporting that uh which we're really
excited about um that's my most impact
maybe my most anticipated any dc
property do we have casting info on that
one colin ferrell oh it's a yeah it's
continuation so it's in the mattress
verse yes and it takes place apparently
right after the flooding and then i'm
assuming there'll be flashbacks to him
penguining like how he becomes but that
gives you the opportunity in my opinion
of the rogues gallery of batman is one
of the best if not the best in comic
books and you don't have time to put
them in every movie and you don't want
to take away from batman in those movies
what you can do is have the crime level
like the the crime mob level villains be
with penguin and then your universe
builds out and then that way you can do
like an arkham movie in the third movie
you've had met those characters already
i think it's a genius move to do a more
linear thing than like i like what
marvel's doing but i think dc could
really learn from marvel and pick the
best things and make the villains as
important as the hero and then build
something yeah that's what i'd do
yeah and and presumably jeffrey wright
is going to be in this as commissioner
gordon maybe some of the other faces we
saw in the matt reeves film um we don't
know a lot yet but uh it's wonderful to
hear that that is still happening as of
now and then speaking of uh batgirl and
the kind of the disastrous cancelling of
that uh the two directors of that film
shared on instagram uh this photo that's
a deal lrb apologies i'm sure i'm
butchering your name sir but um that's a
photo with uh leslie grace's batgirl and
michael keaton as batman
um he shared that this is kind of the
first image of michael keaton in that
film that has gotten out promotional or
otherwise um
yeah which again that will be the only
image that gets out possibly ever uh
i know i mean this is this news has been
out for the last three days so we've
probably all speculated on this what do
you think of the odds that any version
of bad girl ever gets released i think
they'll let it out eventually i don't
think i don't think legally i think i
think a little leak a little leak or lol
here it is on youtube like i think
they shelved it for a very particular
reason that they haven't made known
public yet like everyone even the
directors are like it's unfortunate that
this happened but this is what's
happening but no one has said why
exactly so i think once all that's
happening and or finish happening and
done and you know warner has done all
their business with discovery or
whatever
then they'll probably release it as like
a fine here it is yes why not on hbo max
or whatever they need content yeah they
don't get the tax break like they don't
so the thing is you know i think that's
why we'll see it in any way but i think
the way this is all happening is it's a
big restructure so i i see like we were
talking about here like there's going to
be some big changes and we'll look back
and maybe not until like 10 years and
see why it had to go this way i'm really
bummed for all the creators and i really
want to see it personally i just don't
think the way it's being removed can
legally be shown because i'm sure that's
part of the the write down yes
to get the insurance on it or whatever
it has to be buried in a desert like all
of those e.t nes cartridges and a jug of
money in the middle like in breaking bad
um uh shifting to a little bit of um
marvel news james gunn spoke with
gamespot recently and revealed that
guardians of the galaxy 3 will have a
much much more mature story ooh
guardians after dark
well that's interesting i mean that's
one way to take mature we all think of
like tvma right like there's gonna be uh
that kind of content but like he kind of
then went on to say that like maybe it's
just like a little bit more serious kind
of heartfelt right uh he said much more
mature than the other guardian stories
in a way because you know we started
making these movies that were 10 11
years old or for people that were 10 or
11 years old when they saw them and now
those people are 20 21 the movie has
grown up with them also some people
were roughly 30 when they saw those
movies and now they're roughly 40. okay
so uh thank you guys that's how time
works all kinds of age groups uh enjoyed
those movies i love to think that like
that first guardians movie was made for
a 10 year old that's uh yeah that's a
dark dark journey yeah yeah yeah that'd
be interesting a lot of that round in
the accuser stuff's pretty heavy for
attack oh yeah prison escapes
okay
somebody's coming in
i learned something about myself oh no
what'd you learn tommy i got a lot of
chest hair okay it's a big canvas like
the beautiful canadian territory of
manitoba
it's spread out oh is it hard to
remember so it was tough to write a name
but i want everyone to know
i just went to town
what are we just carving just okay
i think i could see there's there's a
bit of a j situation here
um
some random patches
there's some stuff missing all right i
can say there's a lot missing
i don't know depending if you're
watching in hd at home oh my god
ken
throwing out a big old super chat we
appreciate all of you uh euromaniacs
uh true true trash bags through and
through we appreciate you for that
you're all garbage
um uh but uh speaking of guardians of
the galaxy three um uh he also kind of
gave a synopsis via that same game spot
article
peter quill still reeling from the loss
of gamora must rally his team around him
to defend the universe along with
protecting one of their own
interesting to keep that vague a mission
that if not completed successfully could
quite possibly lead to the end of the
guardians as we know them well we kind
of are assuming this will lead to the
guard and of the guardians as we know
them right and i think that one of their
own is rocket yeah i think that's been
that heavy consumption yeah all the high
evolutionary stuff and a lot of maybe
his backstory interesting and and just
with this whole thing like
i are we going to see some like major
tearjerky well i think that's the mature
tone is like you know and that gives me
a lot of hope for the future of the mcu
as he mentioned i think finally they're
acknowledging that it's been going for
14 years they're finally acknowledging
that people that were 15 are now 30.
they're like those people have grown up
with this but they're ready for mature
themes like deadpool so i'm i'm excited
that things are are being acknowledged
in universe as we've evolved so this
movie sounding darker is a good thing i
wonder why we're not considering the
people that were a hundred that are
ghosts now we really should look at that
enjoy the movie
you're right
it's that whole thing it's like all the
all the people that were uh boston red
sox fans for a hundred years never got
to see a championship right imagine
being you know 90 years old in 2006 yeah
hoping you can just make it to cn games
you know what i mean what what uh yeah
what is james gunn doing for the ghouls
uh uh it's speaking of one last piece of
guardians of the galaxy news is a little
bit more obscure but um michael
rosenbaum
uh the actor best known i think in my uh
book for playing lex luthor
luther
uh series um who's also had kind of a
cameo in guardians of the galaxy vol 2
as a ravager and he kind of confirmed
that there's going to be a little bit of
a ravager reunion yes look at that
that's his character he wouldn't
necessarily know it just from um seeing
that image that kind of looks like the
night king got into a bad car wreck yeah
just
or yeah or doubles as a disco ball in
his off hours or something like that um
but previously they'd already been
announced that sylvester stallone was
going to appear in this yes um and so we
could see yeah that that was the image
from uh volume two right and like a lot
of those characters in the comics were
guardians at one point in another so you
know as we know like maybe this chapter
of the guardians is coming to a close
because that helped launch the next
chapter
i mean those are great actors i don't
know if they would want to do a whole
movie with them but i mean if you have
michelle yo ving rhames miley cyrus
hello hello sly stallone and michael
rosenbomb sign me up put it on streaming
shelve it for 10 years
get that tax break baby
people pointed out uh michelle yo a
talented actress already has another
character in the mcu right so you played
yingnan and shengshi in the legend of
the ten rings
the old double dip
it with michelle yeah uh
she could play three or four characters
in the mcu why not it contains
multitudes we can we can afford it um
okay and then finally another story
we've been tracking all week um as tommy
says chaos breeds content um
the moon knight is show runner mohammed
mohammed diab again if there is a name i
will find a way to mispronounce it um
there's been all this back and forth oh
he's in cairo with oscar isaac are they
[ __ ] they're kind
they might be their shooting stuff yeah
why would why else would we be here
vacation yeah that's a beautiful place
yeah uh but said via twitter there's
been no talk about the
update hardwood floors shave it all the
time i mean here it is i had a great
time the three minutes that i was with
you guys
now how far do we have to go
so yeah we're currently at 306 dollars
if we hit 500 too much money that hair
will end up taped to my chest and i
truly hope everybody stopped donating
money
it's truly my nightmare how dare you
i will personally
take offense with every person that
donates a single dollar from here on out
and i will call you out uh verbally uh
but uh while tommy does that uh we'll
continue as a three-man booth here uh so
david zazzler head of warner brothers
discovery right they cancel a bad girl
they they're firing a bunch of people
probably more people are going to get
fired all this restructuring is these
two huge companies merge a lot of like
bad hints at the future of hbo max in
general
um but he did say
they're going to be hiring new folks to
shepherd in a new 10-year plan for dc
um they're gonna they they name-dropped
kevin feige and bob iger we're gonna try
to model it after what marvel has done
whatever that means we can discuss what
that could mean because marvel's done a
lot of stuff um and he kind of
reiterated that the future of dc is
probably not hbo max based they value
the theatrical release they want to make
big
quality and it was a word he dropped
quality films right that will work in
theaters internationally
um and so this whole like dumping wonder
woman 84. and i know a lot of that was
pandemic related and they're trying to
launch a new streaming service but like
doesn't want to do more of that and i
even love there's a little hint there's
a little uh nugget in his life oh we
just got a major
michelle the king
film juice you're on my [ __ ] list
how dare you
oh i'm i'm hurting for you we're closing
in on you go get some of tommy's jessica
said pubertize the house we are
82 away from a rough friday for you you
know what just just when you think
you're safe
okay but um i i love the little nuggets
as well i've dropped in there of like
they looked at the numbers right and all
these streaming services are uh famously
super secretive about all their watch
numbers right and they just say like
this movie was the most watched movie
ever right whether you're netflix or hbo
max or whatever uh but he said we we
looked at the numbers and it doesn't
make business sense to release a big
movie on a streaming service like none
of it has been worthwhile so like to
netflix with your gray man and your red
notice right to hbo max with their other
big movies uh dune uh dropping the
batman on there almost day and day
interesting to hear from a guy who can
see the actual numbers you're telling me
a family of five watching a movie for
six dollars a month is not conducive
oh there it is shame on you bryce yeah
okay so but
we know they want a new 10-year plan and
so we've kind of had new rock stars
we racked our heads together it feels
like there's about four paths that this
10-year plan could go down and so we're
gonna we're gonna chat about each of
those paths respectively and kind of
pitch why this path could work because
above all we're rooting for dc we want
there to be good dc movies we want there
to be more great superhero movies we
think characters like batman superman uh
aquaman shazam and ones that we haven't
seen as much of hawk hawks
yes we want to see all of them done
really well on the big screen in
addition to the franchises we already
like like wonder woman black adam looks
cool as hell um so kind of the the
different arcs we're thinking of uh and
again be throwing in the chat if you
like any of these more than the others
if you have particular films you want to
see um ideas for these so we're thinking
that like
and this doesn't feel that likely based
on comments from zazlov but the first
and most direct route is they just
continue going the way they're going
right we keep seeing jason momoa as
aquaman we keep seeing gal gadot as
wonder woman et cetera et cetera right
we get these movies we already know are
planned and in the can and presumably
will be released in the next 18 months
and then they continue on with movies
that have been talked about in the past
wonder woman three um
maybe a batman film that is not in the
reeves universe but is in kind of the
dceu shared universe martian manhunter's
been hinted at there's been various
green lantern projects etc etc now
assuming this is the way they go they
kind of take what they already have they
just shine it up around the edges and
find a way to make it work
eric you mentioned one cool way that
this could work and still feel new while
kind of honoring what already exists
yeah i think the dcu could and probably
should go the kind of cw route and make
these dc dceu movies continue making
them but then put them in a shared
universe kind of sort of so it's a
crisis on infinite earth's kind of
situation but on the big screen in movie
theaters so like yeah like so they
introduced martian manhunter at the end
of the the snyder cut yeah uh formally
because he was probably in man of steel
as that general um and yeah they can
make a martial manhunter movie they can
do
uh what's here another suicide squad and
just change one more word or lettering
in the title of that to differentiate
they just put an exclamation mark
right they put a hat symbol in squad
yeah just one more way to make it a
little different
tommy's back i'm back he's looking he's
looking lighter more aerodynamic somehow
somebody get me to an olympic-sized pool
i'm ready to race he's ready to swim
he's got these guys lots of water he's
working hard back there you could also
add the cw shows that have ended to that
and let that be the end of those shows
yeah and like have the tv and film mesh
and that in that movie that'd be that'd
be huge yeah just bring some of the
actors from the cw dc universe into the
dc even the mail back get grant gustin
in there yeah get the i guess
yeah i always forget the guy's name who
has been arrow but he's now on a
wrestling show yeah he's on the
wrestling show heels which is really
good so he's staying in shape he could
throw the green cowl back on and be here
and
bring the arrowverse kind of to the dceu
we could fail the city again absolutely
there's always time and chances to
battle the city
that poor guy failed his city so much
yeah
that's what that's what his superheroes
and i like that right like we're kind of
like uh we're fixing the car while it's
already moving down the road and but
we're giving it a new cool destination
right of like building two like an end
game esque kind of thing like secret
wars because you could then combine the
tv and then make it the scope that
people would deserve to have if it's
going to end that universe i'm reminded
of a
mid-2000s mtv2
classic pimp my ride with this okay what
we're doing is we're taking a broken
down
piece of trash
and we're making it look nice right like
hey i hear you like share universe we're
putting some flat screens in the bag
yeah we're putting a bowling alley in
the front
but in the end does the car run
we hope so we hope so also film juice
how dare you the amount of creativity
you're showing film juice in the
disgusting things you want me to do with
tommy's body
is disturbing this is me shame on you
princess unicorn nipples i love the
screen name
hate the super chat
ryan gudgeon do the thing over tommy
shaved her body i gotta say my shirt
feels so good i'm like oh careless chest
you've never felt more alive okay i like
that plan right and again
we like a lot of these actors some of
these films have been a little hit or
miss but like that's fixable with the
right script the right director whatever
we love jason limo's aquaman i don't
think anybody wants to see him leave
that role right like why not have some
of this continue just kind of again
shaping it maybe having a more cohesive
vision of where it's going i like that
so that's that's plan one keep the car
going the same
same car new direction
of how much money has been raised
how dare you you're 17 away
okay so then uh this might be the only
we only get through the second one here
before i have to go do uh disgusting
things
so the second round and this is like the
polar opposite
hard reboot burn it all down hard reboot
everything you know this reminds me of a
mid-2000s mtv classic
making the band oh yeah let's bring some
fresh voices
into this universe
new batman yes new superman
new mr mixel plicks
everybody needs it do we need a new one
do we have even though we don't
actually let's show them before i have
to do it yeah do you want to see his
[ __ ] i guess compared to that oh
sorry yeah we gotta have this reveal
trying to show off this newly shorn look
at that man
no one can see it
a little patchy and scratchy but uh oh
yeah it's not a perfect job we only have
an hour it's similar to what jessica
clemens did to your the head on your the
herringbone barber clean this up too
yeah that's a lot of business
uh it's it's it's at the mange level of
uh cleanliness right now uh shame on all
of you in the chat uh you're all dead
lord um
what is happening i also get the
craziness
alfred uh
you're all awful people
uh film juice he's back
he must be stopped why does he keep
getting away with it
oh no
he's getting away with it
i want to say teen wolf zach shame on
you
okay but to reboot it all
now i i think this seems somewhat likely
because again you get new management in
they don't want any of old management
stuff to succeed yeah zazzle can't take
credit for gal gadot movies
this chat is going nuts oh my god daddy
should we tease it for the end so that
people stick around and watch i think
it's friday a bunch of people got paid
today he wants to do it right now
i'll show off my uh infant tile look
it's both it's both alarmingly hairless
oh my gosh it is so much worse than i
imagined i don't know why i don't know
what i was expecting
we've been friends for over a decade
but this is the closest we've ever been
is this what you wanted jack tell me why
is your chest hair so long
[Applause]
shout out to my mom who's most likely
watching oh no shout out to my mom who i
hope turned this off hours ago
okay but uh hard reboot so
again
i know can you take anything i say
seriously
we're at the face paint zone
your body here putting anybody's body on
somebody else's body is weird ah okay
it's not question again we're staying
it's it's positive vibes friday that's
right positive friday how could a hard
reboot
work best for dc i personally uh if i
was gonna rebuild dc i would
intentionally try to keep everyone and
even keel so you'd plan out the schedule
right like you'd have every three to six
months another character that way you
actually have momentum i think the thing
that went awry in the first round was it
was one superman movie then suddenly
batman's superman then suddenly justice
league everything felt like they were 20
they were rushing to a thing
so everyone gets their own movie before
justice league so you model it yeah like
and you have a pace if you've got a
10-year plan you can pace this out
correctly i think that's brilliant i
think what they need to do and this is i
i hate to be earnest on this show
this show this episode of all episodes
they need to out fight you feige they
need to get up on a stage get a tight
graphic that's like batman
superman
wonder woman
justice league
justice league two legion of doom and
just put those five out there and then
lots of little question marks in between
and we fill them in with the with the
niche with the with the sauce with the
excellent what's gonna really round it
out but you give us the type five you
give us the fab five the temples you
give us what we want and then you you
tease what's coming in then you can do
the the kind of more obscure your
guardians of the galaxy you're eternals
you're not you know your zatanna you're
dark yeah exactly
you're like go out there and not fight
you fight you can do it guys i think so
and also and so part of the hard reboot
yeah we're probably doing some recasting
that's right we're maybe getting some
new like
you need a a visionary to guide the
universe right at the level of a feige
or or nolan was kind of doing it for dc
a little bit back in the day and
certainly snyder had his run right like
you need somebody with that kind of a
top level creative vision bring in bruce
tim he could do it he did it with the
cartoons no that's a great call
yeah
have kevin
like this is a positive thing like
marvel did have the occasional stumble
and some things didn't work you could
plant more appropriate easter eggs you
can do things that feel more natural
like when you go back and watch iron man
the immediately next thing was
incredible hulk that didn't end up
working out because they used ruffalo
and then iron man 2 felt rushed like
certain things didn't work and yet the
net positive marvel is very positive
because there's a plan i would argue dc
is more than more good than bad even now
i like more than i don't like from dc
but with a fresh reboot you can truly
take the time to make it all perfect yes
also i just want to point out we've
raised too much money too much
you're all disgusting um you're awful
john also kate producer john came in
here to set up a specific camera angle
off yeah
[Music]
is happening on my chest um shame on all
of you uh i think we should still
continue on this segment but
we got to pay manscape respects for all
the hard work that's right let's get
that ad in it's 350 almost yes so let's
thank them before we get back into this
yes yeah before we talk about the other
two pass dc could take we do want to
shout out manscape who's been sponsoring
the show all week
one yes
i used to be hairy
yeah
what of it
it's no secret manscape
saved my ass from some hairy harassment
over the years so you can imagine why i
was absolutely excited when they
sponsored us we want to thank manscape
for sponsoring us this week
i highly recommend the performance
package 4.0 with the lawnmower 4.0 which
i took from neck
to head
today okay
and let me tell you it's designed to
reduce grooming accidents i had a few
but those were all user operated nothing
to do with the machine you were doing a
poorly lit bathroom mirror
i was in there crying
anyway
it it's it's made to reduce grooming
accidents and help shave loose skin
which god knows my skin is loose and
ready my skin's ready to get out and
date i got a ceramic blade advanced skin
safe technology it also has an led light
to allow you to mow the lawn in the dark
and i say you haven't lived
so you don't pay your electric bill and
you got to shave your sack in total
darkness exactly you can even it doubles
as if you want to tell ghost stories
that's true
that's true
you haven't lived until you hold a
trimmer to your face telling a ghost
story a bunch of terrified
victims you kidnapped anyway with the
performance package purchased
two free gifts not guilty don't trust
the media the shed travel bag the
reduced chafing manscape boxes i'm
telling you you give me free underwear
i'll do anything yeah i'll go anywhere
for you they have a bunch of other
products too on their website god knows
i use them crop reviver come on baby
let's do it so they're going to give you
20 off plus free shipping if you use our
code break room i've said it all week if
you haven't done it yet what's what's
wrong with you that's 20 off with free
shipping at manscape.com use our code
break room baby then it makes us look
good okay keep your lawn clean and
pristine and if there's one thing we
value on this show it's looking good
that's right looking professional yes
looking mature and adult keep your chest
a mess
keep your long clean and pristine keep
your ass
ready to pass
with the ultimate bushwhacking tool from
manscape thank you manscaping we
genuinely
thank you
thank you man god i thank you they do
not endorse the use of their product uh
in this way yeah in the very specific
way we've done it today but we see it
works but you can tell no one from legal
stopped
they didn't send anyone via helicopter i
want to say real quick now that we've
gotten before we get back into this
shame on all of you shame on alfred rioz
shame on alice 274.
whitaker i'm from montana
kenny g 420
you're good
this is me
film james
back he must be stopped oh god go buy a
scratch off do something
buy a lego
blind bag mario figurine do something
else man we don't have any more hair to
give
i got nothing leg gave everything to you
people
not everything he's got no no eric don't
give him that idea
don't give him that idea if we raise ten
thousand dollars
i'll take all my skin off
i'll just be you don't know what
oligarch's watching
it's friday it's honest someone goes
i've always wanted to see you well
there's a little full slim good body
over here at the table oh man great
right right i used to watch that show
all the time i just aged myself um okay
the third option for the dc eu that we
were talking about right right and this
is doubling down on what a lot of people
have enjoyed the most especially in the
last 18 months it's one of the few dc
things we've gotten the reeves universe
named after matt reeves director of the
batman pattinson uh pat battinson's uh
film and maybe like doubling down on
that and expanding out from there if you
explain it out enough obviously you have
the kind of like the characters close to
batman that make a lot of sense
nightwing razor ghoul you can kind of
expand some of those villains that that
koi was referencing before through hbo
max or or films but then you keep
expanding enough you could get your
superman and your green lantern in there
too right can i say something
this reminds me
of an early 2000s mtv2 show
teen mom okay okay because it started
off as teen mom
then we got teen mom too it was a little
alternative yeah people were a little
uncomfortable different moms we weren't
used to that type of mom we liked our
moms in their 20s their 30s their 40s a
teen mom that's a tough situation we get
teen mom too we get teen mom reunion we
have multiple shows
yes t-mobile g i mean they the titles
invent themselves guys keep it in the
team mom universe keep it in the matt
reeves universe this is a simple clean
solution i'm all for this guys i just
yeah i really quick when i call out you
could pray to who's clearly a disturbed
individual says that a thousand dollars
would give daddy a stash
coming from him
somebody a coming up somebody somebody
check on utica prieta right now uh they
are clearly
insane but you know what
it's so crazy it just might work
if we had a thousand dollars yeah i will
put this discussion here on my way yes
don't do it i'm begging you not to give
any another dime i'm begging you not to
give another dime
i don't know if we can handle it on this
side
yeah i got a page from this yes please
so with with two and three i'd combine
them so i would say reboot it all but
you also expand the reeves universe and
that's kind of what the comics are right
now there's this thing called dc black
label and it is all of the characters
but they're all in a darker tone and no
one's confused it's a different format
it feels different i would let matt
reeves continue out his universe i'd let
him get to robins and nightwings and all
those things but the thing that we like
about matt reeves universe is it's 85 90
grounded yeah i don't want to see a
grounded superman i want to see superman
i don't want to see green lantern have
to deal with space cop stuff on earth i
want to see him space cop i want the
expanded universe of dc not to worry
about batman and then when you do the
reboot at all i'd have that batman
introduced as someone that's aware of
these gods and never have batman fight
superman it doesn't make sense have
batman and superman be two sides of the
same justice coin and then you have
batman once you get to the justice
league be your eye line for how we
humans would interact with gods have the
elements of the gods in the justice
league but keep your mat reeves batman
separate from your dc batman so you have
like a dc black label as well as your
regular dc universe and that way as
you're expanding these matt reeves can
do his penguin show we can have that
darker universe we can have arkham we
can have barry keown as joker and then
you can find out if you have a darker
character like constantine he could go
to matt reeves land and you can have
your dc characters that are the
archetypal brighter characters in our dc
universe keep them separate yeah that's
what i would do i would reboot it and
then dc black label it
i
wow that's what i'd do that would be let
me have it that would be awesome
i have reason to believe huckabee and
film juice are working
i would like to start an fbi case file i
believe the two of them have joined
forces and created what i like to call a
cell
a cell
a cell of evil uh yes yeah clearly
whatever is going on it's it's dark boy
i love that idea it's a deep state and
it's terrible cosmic green lantern will
be the guardians you know what i mean i
want those things and i don't want him
worried about how like matt reeves
batman's doing yeah like
i also don't want joker and harley quinn
to necessarily come in you know i mean
yeah
yeah yeah that'd be interesting and it
kind of pivots into maybe the fourth
possible angle that we were talking
about and that's like
nothing shared let everything live in
its own universe we know we're getting
joker too and it will not connect to
battenson it will not connect to any
other dc property right right uh it gets
to live on its own island and tell the
story at once and we didn't have a new
harley quinn or a new uh bruce wayne or
whatever um and maybe we can do that for
all the properties now that it would be
interesting because that would fly in
the face of like modeling anything after
marvel yeah the whole premise of marvel
is everything at least has the potential
to show up anywhere everybody got
snapped everybody knows who tony stark
is yadda yadda but like
how could this really work for dc uh-oh
to caillou him
we may not get a werewolf by night
special on disney plus this year
but can we also acknowledge the benefit
of the nothing is connected now if you
look at what's happening this year with
marvel i think the marvel phase four
films i've enjoyed for the most part but
i think the biggest problem has been fan
expectation versus delivery i had i gone
into multiverse of madness without
having seen the multiverse trailer would
have had more of a good time with the
sam rainey film i think waiting for
things to be connected is a flaw
inherently unless you know how to do it
long game so i think there's an absolute
benefit to having nothing is connected
and that's why i have these two
universes i'd run parallel universes one
where nothing's connected one where
things are audiences are 15 years into
peak superhero culture we don't have to
worry about aunts in idaho not
understanding anymore we get it now you
can have both of these things co-exist
without having to worry about they're
being like why are there two badmintons
there's three batman's right now
there is yeah that's true and one of
them is not even showing up anywhere
this reminds me of an early 2000s mtv2
show called true life
a doctor series where every episode
covered a different kind of life they
weren't connected but they all had the
same title and you knew it was honest it
was a true life one time a guy wanted
calf implants he was obsessed with
getting calf implants we followed that
for an hour they gave chris rock his own
true life and me i remember watching the
chris rock true life and he pretends to
kick it he's standing in line at the
supermarket and he's pretending to kick
the guy in front of him in the butt like
he's just standing there winding up and
kicking him it was the fun google it if
you need to that's our joker everybody
there's one person that deserves a
thanks everyone else deserves jeers and
tomatoes i want to thank koi
for taking this show seriously today and
offering
actual content that is digestible in
what we normally do i want to say to
everyone else
you blew it
we all blew it we all failed thank you
for introducing me to onsen idaho that's
going to be my yeah
uncle's in the upper peninsula
yeah i like this i mean just as somebody
i enjoyed joker i've enjoyed a lot of
the dc films you know if if you're if
you're hoping for especially if you're a
fan of filmmakers maybe you subscribe to
auteur theory whatever
uh
again me trying to make serious coaching
points like this
like you want to set up directors for as
much success as possible or writers
actors everything and like
letting them make a great two hour two
and a half hour film without worrying
about what comes next or how it connects
to something else right lets them make
the best possible single movie yeah
right and like yeah wouldn't we love to
see like a killer plastic man film that
doesn't need to connect to a batman or a
superman or anybody else because if you
look at the medium of comic books you're
inherently allowing creativity into your
consent like your digestion of it right
like you're you're the one that's moving
the panels you're the one that's
thinking of the action between the
panels a movie is a different medium
it's telling you how to receive that
information it's painting the picture
for you inherently batman and superman
can coexist in a comic book easier than
in a movie because we're hiring two
actors that are of the same species to
act like superheroes so by the nature of
the mediums you need to adjust your
plans accordingly and i think that's the
strength of starting over
yeah i love it absolutely john hit the
graphic oh
it's time for mandatory fun the segment
that has swept the nation where i get my
three best friends to say goodbye
[ __ ] the show is over
uh we did have a we had a fun mandatory
fun planned and you know what it'll
still be fun next week we're gonna do it
on monday uh and i'll just uh though i
will tease it just a little bit it
involves simulu yeah come on the show
see you know
come on come on guys
tag him on twitter let him know we want
him on the breaker we want to talk
barbie with him yes yes
we want to talk
mcu and especially barbies mostly
barbies mostly
thank you
everybody um we are going to um play our
clip of the week yeah fyi if you're not
already a member of the discord it's
it's free for anybody who's an adult to
join um and you don't have to
emotionally be an adult just legally an
adult um 18 and up um and on the discord
you can clip out your favorite clip from
any episode of the break room for that
week and uh you know 45 seconds of time
he's saying something funny uh 32
seconds of tommy saying something
ridiculous yeah uh 16 minutes of me
interrupting jessica
brandon or zach or eric
yeah yeah other people and it could be
yeah people making cogent points but
most likely it's going to be somebody
saying something uh stupid or ridiculous
or funny used honda we could buy with
the money raised i know alfred rios
the worst thing is it all goes towards
clubbing seals
tell them that's the thing though
there's no clubbing like they go out to
them
these are nightclubs limousine lifestyle
seals
slip and slide they love it
yeah or club iceberg yeah straight from
there it's smaller every year that's
also a penguin reference which ties into
our show today yeah it's for the lounge
yes it's all connected but it is
different
dc eu extended right there that's what
i'm saying to do you folks and thanks
everyone saying i should have dc
producers i should tag them tell them i
want to work for them yeah
yeah
more checks
by the way i know we spread it out over
a lot of the show but uh you the
audience voted on which route which one
of these routes is as we presented today
dc should go an overwhelming majority
saying reboot it all burn it down hard
reboot hey
i don't think you're wrong i like that
route too audience
um which ravagers should join the
guardians a lot a lot of left for sly
stone sliced alone sorry sly stone was a
great uh [ __ ] musician from the 70s uh
sylvester stallone of course uh talented
actor um and we're gonna play our uh
current clip of the week we got a bunch
submitted by viewers and then the staff
here in the rock stars picked their
favorite john do you got that bad boy
queued up
let's cast our dream star wars baseball
team okay bat boy little luke skywalker
you're starting with bad boys
[Music]
uh okay
uh equipment manager maz kanata uh
always there with the gadgets
okay uh at catcher
job of the hut why he's as big as the
backstop big hands okay right a pitcher
i'm gonna say jar jar binks because
listen to me listen to me we all make
fun of jar jar binks but he could fling
things
really fast oh yeah really fast so if
jar jar binks is pitching at shortstop
he'll be one canary hello there you know
you need someone agile someone could
stop the balls
at first base my boy darth vader why
because you got to be a vacuum cleaner
at first place you gotta be a vacuum
cleaner a ball's in the dirt stop it
with the force
there it is